Це карантинний рейд у колишній столиці Німеччини місті Бонн.
Патруль відомства громадського порядку виїхав проконтролювати, як виконуються обмежувальні заходи,
за допомогою яких влада намагається якщо не зупинити,
то хоча б уповільнити поширення коронавірусу в Німеччині.
Раніше працівники відомства в основному перевіряли,
чи закрилися вчасно кафе і магазини та чи правильно припарковані автомобілі.
Нині ж патрулюють парки і ловлять тих, хто збирається великими групами.
Правоохоронцям також допомагають, як би сказали в Україні, сусіди-стукачі -
у Німеччині ж це пильні громадяни.
У нас є центральний офіс відомства правопорядку.
Стурбовані мешканці телефонують туди, коли бачать порушників,
тих, хто збирається групами на ігрових майданчиках,
біля спортивних закладів, на березі Рейну, в парках.
Ну, і, звісно, ми знаємо популярні місця на Рейні, парки, де люди зазвичай люблять проводити час.
Ми патрулюємо ці місця і перевіряємо, чи не робить хтось щось заборонене.
За порушення заборони німцям загрожує штраф від 200 євро до 5 тисяч євро,
а в разі повторних порушень і до 25 тисяч євро.
За проведення пікніків, приміром, кожен учасник має сплатити 250 євро,
а за участь у забороненому заході 400 євро.
Штраф 5 тисяч євро загрожує власникам закладів,
які продовжуватимуть роботу, незважаючи на заборону.
А за зустрічі понад 10 осіб передбачено навіть позбавлення волі на строк до 5 років.
У перший день дії заборони у колишній столиці Західної Німеччини
Бонні зловили лише чотирьох порушників.
При цьому перебувати на відкритому повітрі та займ атися спортом не заборонено.
Прогулюватися можна лише вдвох або з тими, з ким живеш в одній оселі.
До обмежень свого приватного життя жителі Німеччини в основному ставляться з розумінням.
Я переживаю, що можу заразитися. А також через фінансову кризу, яка, схоже, буде значною.
Багато хто дотримується правил, тому я думаю, що більш серйозні заходи не будуть впроваджувати.
Я більше не можу ходити в спортзал, з друзями в бар, не показують футбол,
але крім цього в моїй рутині мало що змінилося.
Нині більше не можна зустрітися з друзями.
Ми вже влаштовуємо вечірки по скайпу. Але поки можна зустрічатися удвох, не так все погано.
У землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія, де знаходиться Бонн,
найбільша кількість заражених коронавірусом порівняно з іншими частинами Німеччини -
понад 10 тисяч.
У сусідньому з Бонном місті Кельн зростання числа нових випадків в останні кілька днів сповільнилося,
тому є надія, що вжиті заходи починають працювати,
каже бургомістр Кельна і глава кризового штабу міста Штефан Келлер.
Перш ніж ще більше обмежувати свободу людей, ми повинні переконатися, що заходи,
які ми вже запровадили, не працюють.
Тому що ми дійсно сильно обмежуємо свободу людей, і з цим потрібно бути дуже обережним.
Немає жодних причин забороняти громадянину перебувати на свіжому повітрі.
Йому не дозволяється робити це в групі, йому не дозволяється заражати кого-небудь ще,
але він, звичайно, може гуляти наодинці, виходити на пробіжку, їздити на велосипеді.
Поки він робить це один, це навіть корисно для здоров'я, і ​​ми не повинні забороняти це.
Не заборонено і знайомитися, приміром, через "Тіндер".
Як пише на своїй сторінці у Твіттері поліція Берліна,
такі зустрічі проходять лише удвох і зазвичай обмежуються лише розмовами.
А от в гості ходити не можна - ані до друзів, ані до родичів.
Відвідувати можна лише чоловіка чи дружину або партнера чи партнерку.
Ми здійснюємо контроль за дотриманням нових правил вже кілька днів.
І ми помічаємо, що дедалі більше людей ставляться до ситуації серйозно. Поводяться обережніше.
Це видно і в громадському транспорті, і під час наших патрулювань.
Водночас, ми щоразу бачимо, що є власники магазинів, які не дотримуються нових правил,
і тут нашим колегам доводиться втручатися. І наполягати на дотриманні правил.
Більшість громадян поводяться законослухняно, але дехто все ж порушує -
проти таких з моменту запровадження посилених заходів 23 березня вже відкрито близько 200 справ.
Загалом поліція проконтролювала кілька сотень об'єктів у всьому місті,
серед яких були відкриті вуличні кафе, квіткові магазини, перукарні та нічні клуби.
Серед поліцейських у Берліні виявлено щонайменше два десятки випадків
зараження коронавірусом.
Крім того, понад чотириста поліцейських відправили на карантин.
Але у міському поліцейському управлінні запевняють,
що сил на підтримку правопорядку в столиці Німеччини вистачить.
Наше головне завдання - мінімізувати ризики для здоров'я тоді,
коли люди стоять дуже близько одне до одного.
Тому наші колеги й "прочісують" усю територію міста, зупиняють групи людей, розмовляють з ними.
Ми діємо стримано й адекватно, але якщо бачимо, що люди просто не реагують,
то ми зобов'язані порушувати справи.
Повну заборону виходити на вулицю, як в Італії, Франції чи Іспанії,
влада Німеччини поки запроваджувати не збирається.
Пояснюють це тим, що німці загалом законослухняніші
і дисциплінованіші, і що чинних обмежень поки достатньо, аби зупинити поширення коронавірусу.